we know when you find the volume of a
prism or a cylinder the formula is
basically the same right it's volume
equals the area of the base times the
height okay now what you can think of
okay let's take a look at the cylinder
one first you can think of a stack of
coins for example so see you had a bunch
of coins like this okay just kind of
visualize with me for a moment imagine
they are stacked up like this a bunch of
pennies right or dimes or nickels or
quarters right so if you were to take
the stack of let's see one two three
four five six seven about eight coins
right and if I was to go over here and
push these over here and line them up do
you think that when I go to push them
over here that they would be the same
height taller or shorter well if you
said the same height you're absolutely
right because when I go to push these
over see the height of each coin is just
you know whatever it is right so it's
like it's like they're just um
sliding horizontally so if we go ahead
and do that now see one two three four
five six seven eight okay so my drawing
isn't perfect but if you can see if you
were to slide these over they're gonna
have the exact same height so when you
think about the volume you know the
volume of each individual coin is the
same you know we're not stretching it or
compressing it so if we take the volume
of all these coins add it up it's just
going to be the volume of one coin times
eight the value of one coin times eight
so it's the same volume so long story
short you just find the area of the base
but what you want is you want that
perpendicular height okay the height
that's to a right angle to the base so
over here what we want is we want this
height right here which should be the
same as this height over here they're
exactly the same so let's go over now to
this diagram here so we've got a square
prism but it's oblique okay it's at an
angle like this and so what we're going
to do is we're gonna find the area of
the base which is 4 times 4 that's 16
times the height which is 8 and so that
comes out to a hundred and twenty eight
centimeters cubed okay for the cylinder
now okay same thing we want to find the
volume it's the area of the base but the
base is a circle so what we want is
pi r squared times the height now
sometimes they try to trick you a little
bit they give you this angled height
here okay 13 we want the perpendicular
height right there so you can see by
doing Pythagorean theorem we have five
squared plus h squared equals 13 squared
5 squared plus h squared equals 13
squared so that's 25 plus h squared
equals 169 subtract 25 from both sides
we get 144 and if you take the square
root of both sides you can see that
height is 12 so let's go ahead and put
that in there we know the height is 12
we know that the radius is half the
diameter so that's 2.5 squared times pi
which is 3.14 and if we multiply that
together let me go ahead and do that see
I don't have my calculator handy with me
right now but if you multiply those
together that's going to give you the
volume and it doesn't matter again that
it's on an angle like that just make
sure you get that perpendicular height
and you've got it so I hope this helped
you know how to understand working with
oblique cylinders or oblique prisms
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon